hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work the art of
rhetoric aristotle is going to discuss
anger among the many other emotions
and he tells us a lot of interesting
things about how anger works as you
could call it a psychological
set of dynamics and among those
is a very short discussion
that is well worth unpacking it has to
do with
the
types of people
that
other people including ourselves will
get angrier in the presence of or you
know when thinking about or we will talk
about what the scope of this is when
somebody else does things that anger us
literally when we are slighted the greek
term is olaguria being made less and you
remember that there's different types of
sliding consisting in contempt or spite
or insult
and the focus here though is not on the
two people the anger
and the angered it's on the presence or
you could call it the witness of a third
person or group of people
aristotle tells us that in these
situations
people become more angry the anger is
intensified and we can think about all
different modes in which this greater or
malone
in greek
occurs so the intensification of anger
towards the offending person
it might be getting angrier in terms of
the intensity of it you know i feel
angrier it could be that it shows itself
in attitude or action i'm more likely to
raise my voice to shout to punch people
to break things to do other
typical actions associated with anger
it might actually spill over onto
a wider range of
people
or it could be getting angry for too
long of a time right there's a lot of
different ways in which this greater or
more this intensifier can take place and
we should also talk about the
being slighted before or in front of
pros
in greek so prose is a
term
that is used to denote
quite literally
being
in front of but it can also mean in
relationship to so
a prime example of this
would be when
you have an email exchange that gets a
little bit testy or salty
and you know people could get angry in
this and then somebody hits reply
all and it goes out to everybody or they
copy and paste
parts of your email you can get angrier
even though we're only talking about a
virtual situation this might also extend
to imagining yourself being in the
presence of or being seen by
these other types of people and
aristotle says that they are five he
says bros penta
in greek and so what are these five
types you notice that for
four of them there are a kind of
parallel that's drawn right
in terms of admiration
their admiration we'll talk about what
that means in just a moment it could be
a little bit broader than that same
thing with respect but then we have this
first group and interestingly in pretty
much all of the english translations
that i've seen
this term is translated as people who
are
our rivals and what is a rival it's
somebody who is sort of on the same
level
as us
and we're always trying to outdo them
and they're trying to outdo us so it
could be
fellow
you know academics
in my case you know scholars i'm gonna
write a book oh he's already writing a
book can i get my book out first you
know we're rivaling each other over that
it could be co-workers
it could be fellow managers if you you
know have attained some sort of position
it could be
rivalry in terms of other things that
are not work related like
i like my yard to look really really
great and my neighbor across the street
is also trying to make their yard look
really really great and people pass by
and they're like oh look at that yard
look at this yard that's a kind of
rivalry it could also be in terms of
other things now
the word that aristotle actually uses
here
is more often translated in terms
of um desiring status being ambitious
looking for
honors quite literally loving honors
philip to ti muntai so philo filene is
the the love or desire or affinity for
something and to muntai is coming from
team which means social status or honor
and so rivals are rivals precisely
because what their rivalry is really
about is not who can make the most money
it's rather what the money signifies or
who has the most beautiful lawn but what
the lawn itself signifies the honor
the social regard that goes along with
it so when we are being insulted put
down whatever it's going to be sliding
when we're in the presence of our rivals
people who we take seriously
we are liable to get more angry with the
person
who is angering us not with the rival
him or herself but rather with the
person who is dishonoring us
in the face of those who we are striving
for honor
with
so that's that's one important class now
we get to the second and
third and the greek term that aristotle
is using here is uh
you know
and hoop hon
and
thalmodzin is the word that we
translate when we say philosophy begins
in wonder right
so wondering or being in awe of
seeing somebody for example as a star
right
that is an example of thalmodzin
we could also
use the term admire those who we hold in
high regard and we marvel at because of
that so it could be musicians it could
be
um you know people in our field i've had
encounters where i meet somebody whose
books i've read and greatly you know
liked and i'm admiring them right you
know a good example of that would be
when i got to be in a faculty seminar
with aleister mcintyre you're kind of
struck
by by uh
that admiration as you come in turns out
he's very down-to-earth and uh very
practical uh very interested in what
other people have to say not a respecter
of persons and so you know it was
possible for a friend friendly relation
rather than a mere admiration
relation to arise and you could say that
there's a lot of people
that one might have this with i remember
uh one time when we were in a restaurant
in washington dc because my wife was
attending a conference there and there
was a you know the secret service were
there as well and people were like oh i
wonder who it is and then michelle obama
came walking out she was in you know
very tall and people were like
you know uh kind of star struck over
that as well so that you know people who
we admire now
when we're insulted
or belittled or humiliated
in front of people who we admire
aristotle is saying the natural tendency
is not just to get angry but to get
angrier
and it also works the other way
people who
now notice what he says here he doesn't
say people who we are admired by
it's not that simple of a transition
people who we wish
to be
admired by
uh huppon
is this desiring this wishing
to be admired
by right the the those
for whom with whom by whom
we want to be
admired and
this is quite important we might aerosol
doesn't necessarily think
that we care that much about those who
do admire us
getting insulted in front of them it's
the ones that we
want to be admired by so perhaps that
could include some of the people we are
admired by
and it wouldn't include some of the
others the ones were like i don't care
what they think right i care what these
people think what they feel and now i
get angrier in relation to this person
who is you know lowering my social
status and we see a similar thing
happening with the fourth and the fifth
the second pair
that status is playing a very important
role here
and you know it's a decent translation
to say those that they respect it's
literally
those before whom
they
could feel a sense of shame right
and
the the
core relative entoys
is
right
so
those who we
respect those whose opinions and values
and judgments we care about
we are liable to get angrier when we are
insulted or put down
when we're in their presence
because it sort of strikes us more right
maybe we fear that they're not going to
respect us unless we
retaliate so there's a lot going
on there and then he says
it's not just with those who we respect
where we're in a sort of you know going
upward relation to them it's also those
who
respect us
or at least we think that they respect
us
when we are put down in front of them we
get angrier we dig our heels in more we
retaliate more quickly or more
vengefully
so a lot of this is you could think
about
maintaining or restoring one's social
position whether it be understood in
terms of respect
or
admiration
or rivalry we could say esteem in
general
all of this is a very important
set of ideas that we have to keep in
mind when we see people getting
angry or
ourselves getting angry
in ways that seem
out of proportion out of place
perhaps what's going on
is we are being angered in the face of
or in the presence of or in relation to
some of these people and knowing that
allows us to perhaps introduce a bit
more practical rationality to our anger
response and
tamp it down a bit uh realizing this
would be a
helpful
cognitive
um
let's call it
assistance right and there's another
important upshot of this if we're going
to do things that we think are going to
anger other people and we don't want to
make them angrier
maybe we don't do it
in front of these other people if i know
that
for example my wife and i are going to
disagree about something and she's
probably going to get angry about it
maybe i don't do that in front of her
rival or people who she admires or wants
to be admired by or respect or is
respected by because i'm kind of setting
things up to have more of a response we
can be
better in how we approach people and how
we set up situations
um
by attending to these important
psychological factors
you